Brasil se encuentra en alerta máxima a
unos días de la investidura de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva como nuevo
presidente del país sudamericano la
policía desactivó una serie de
explosivos encontrados A las afueras de
Brasilia
Esta no es una acción individual y no lo
permitiremos en Brasil
y no es el primer hecho similar un día
antes su nombre fue detenido cuando
intentaba detonar un artefacto explosivo
en el aeropuerto de la capital brasileña
de manera casi paralela un empresario
Fue capturado tras confesar que había
plantado una bomba dentro de un camión
cisterna de combustible para provocar
caos e impedir la toma de posesión de
Lula el primero de enero en la cual
participarán unas 300.000 personas
incluyendo varios jefes de estado
desde que líder progresista fue elegido
para su tercer mandato en octubre los
grupos bolsonaristas más radicales se
han concentrado frente a cuarteles del
ejército pidiendo un golpe de estado que
evite la investidura de Lula
debemos anticiparnos a ciertos actos
porque no puede haber un vacío de poder
esto no va a pasar en la madrugada del
primero de enero vamos a tomar medidas
para que no se dé esta situación de
inestabilidad
también el Ministerio prevé una nueva
regulación para los clubes de tiro los
cuales se han incrementado desde 2019
según señalan las autoridades